NARRATOR: 10 miles up and in the
path of an oncoming Montana
storm, Jake's top
tracker Clutch has
cornered a lion for the
second time in just two hours.
All right.
I see Clutch right here.
NARRATOR: And he's
not giving up.
We're about 80
yards, and the cat's
just about 14 feet above him.
NARRATOR: The dogs are
trained to stay on a lion
until Jake releases them.
He's doing a good job.
The cat's focused on him.
NARRATOR: But after three
chases in a single day,
Jake can't afford another.
It's really important that I
sneak in here quietly and grab.
'Cause if she jumps again,
we could be in for a long,
long night.
[barking]
[growling]
Good boy, Clutch.
Good boy.
Good boy, Clutch, man.
Clutch, he's climbing, and
I've got to tie him up quick.
Clutch.
Come here, bud.
Hey.
Clutch, come on down.
Clutch.
See, this is kind of
what I don't want here.
He's high enough now
that I can't reach him.
And when he falls, he's
gonna make a hell of a fall.
Dogs climbing trees is
definitely not a good habit.
They want these dogs to be as
aggressive as I can get them,
but that definitely comes
with a little bit of risk.
Come here.
Clutch.
I just need to get my hands on
Clutch before that lion jumps.
The sun's burning away fast,
so we're running out of light.
Clutch, man.
Come here, bud.
Clutch.
Ooh, this is gonna hurt.
Oh!
You're not supposed
to jump over me, bud.
Good boy.
Well, that was successful,
believe it or not.
All right.
Well, it's time to make
it off the mountain here.
Good boy, Clutch.
Come on.
NARRATOR: With the lion
retreating far off the ranch,
the threat is
finally contained--
for today.
It's been a very,
very successful season.
And I definitely
established my name,
and I'm growing more
of a reputation.
Good boy.
Let's go.
Come on, Clutch, man.
Load up.
The biggest thing is
when you get that call,
you gotta be ready
and drop everything
and go make it
happen, tree that cat
and just take care
of the problem.
When the snow melts,
hopefully the lions
end up following the game
up and out of the valleys
to the top of the mountain.
But if they don't, we'll
be waiting for him.